et notre première invité politique ce
matin c'est Stanislas Guérini bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ministre
de la transformation et de la fonction
publique on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
évidemment parler de la réforme des
retraites puisque vous êtes l'un des
ministres à l'oeuvre dans cette réforme
elle a été présentée hier en conseil des
ministres l'exécutif qui reste ferme sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans vous restez sourd à la mobilisation
qui s'est exprimée jeudi dernier dans la
rue je crois pas qu'on puisse dire qu'on
est sourd quand on a pendant des
semaines discuter échanger avec les
organisations syndicales fait bouger le
projet de loi on l'a rappelé hier le
projet de loi qui a été présenté c'est
pas le projet de loi qui était envisagé
initialement sur beaucoup d'aspects sur
l'âge je rappelle que le Président de la
République a fait campagne sur un report
de l'âge à 65 ans c'est pas le choix qui
a été fait au final avec 64 ans avec une
augmentation de la durée de cotisation
mais aussi sur bien d'autres aspects je
viens devant vous en tant que ministre
de la Fonction publique en ayant intégré
en ayant enrichi le texte proposé de
beaucoup de modifications qui étaient
portées par les syndicats je porte à des
mesures très importantes sur la retraite
progressive sur la portabilité des
droits pour les catégories actives tout
ça c'est le fruit du dialogue social il
y a quand même eu plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue la semaine
dernière ce que vous attendiez à une
mobilisation pareil et qu'est-ce que ça
change mais vous savez nous on n'est pas
là pour faire des pronostics de
mobilisation mais personnellement
[Musique]
sincèrement moi je me suis jamais livré
au débat de savoir combien il y aurait
de personnes dans la rue c'est la
démocratie les gens ont manifesté ils
ont manifesté des désaccords de la
colère parfois des inquiétudes aussi qui
montrent qu'il faut qu'on continue à
savoir aucun impact sur votre façon
d'aborder
un impact on va maintenant après avoir
présenté le texte rentrer dans un temps
parlementaire et donc les parlementaires
vont pouvoir enrichir le texte bouger
les lignes nous on a été clair
je rappelle aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est l'équilibre c'est pas un gros mot
parler d'équilibre pas simplement une
vision financière pour se faire plaisir
l'équilibre d'un système de retraite
c'est la garantie de la solidarité entre
les générations c'est la garantie que en
réalité on continue de préserver un
système par répartition parce que un
système de retraite qui n'est plus
équilibrée ce n'est plus un système pas
répartition donc ça c'est le cadre que
nous fixons et si dans ce cadre là on
peut continuer à corriger des inégalités
continuer à travailler sur la question
des carrières hachées continuer à
travailler sur la question du travail
des seniors sur toutes ces questions qui
sont essentielles et qui sont au fond au
cœur du débat de société c'est-à-dire
sur la qualité du travail et bien il
faudra le faire bien entendu mais il me
semble que autant il est lég et
démocratique que les français qui sont
en désaccord avec cette réforme puisse
manifester il est tout aussi légitime
que le gouvernement est singulièrement
le président de la République a présenté
un programme aux Français puisse
présenter un projet de loi et le
soumettre à discussion au Parlement sauf
que le cœur de cette contestation et
vous l'avez entendu je dis dans la rue
c'est la question des 74 ans est-ce
qu'il y a pas eu aussi une erreur du
gouvernement de faire tourner cette
réforme autour des 64 ans aux autres
mesures elles sont pas très audibles
reconnaissez-le vous savez je pense que
c'est jamais très populaire que de
réclamer un effort collectif moi je
pense que si on veut être entendu
crédible sur l'amélioration du système
que nous proposons il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont oui c'est un
effort que nous demandons et c'est une
réforme qui est d'abord nécessaire je
crois que c'est très important de le
dire comme ça pour pouvoir simplement
être crédible
elle est nécessaire pourquoi en réalité
pour des raisons démographiques et qu'il
faut répéter parce que c'est très
important de le comprendre dans les
années 60 il y avait quatre actifs pour
un retraité aujourd'hui il y a 1,7 actif
pour un retraité et donc quand on pose
ce fait pas une opinion se fait
incontestable on voit bien qu'elle
nécessitait de porter cette réforme
j'insiste sur le fait que nous aurions
pu rester sourd pour reprendre votre
expression et dire nous on avait dit 65
ans ça reste 64 ans 165 ans et on a fait
un choix différent un choix qui me
semble plus juste d'ailleurs de combiner
la durée de utilisation hélas de départ
à la retraite c'est déjà le fruit
le régime vous vous voyez bien que ça
passe pas on entend beaucoup de Français
qui disent mais 12 milliards de déficits
de série on a mis des milliards pendant
le covid pourquoi on peut pas mettre 12
milliards pourquoi on peut pas aller les
chercher à rien d'abord si vous voulez
parfaitement populaire vous ne faites
pas de réforme des retraites et vous
êtes bien plus tranquille comme ça
est-ce que vous faites ce qui correspond
à votre responsabilité je ne crois pas
et donc notre responsabilité c'est de
porter les réformes qui nous semblent
nécessaires et au fond juste pour les
prochaines générations parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut expliquer aussi si on
réforme pas le système de retraite
mécaniquement les pensions de retraite
vont baisser et d'ailleurs personne ne
conteste ce fait là mécaniquement les
pensions de nos parents de nos
grands-parents mais aussi de nos enfants
et petits-enfants vont baisser voire
même le système sera en danger et donc
c'est pour ça alors bien sûr c'est pas
la réforme la plus populaire elle ne
l'était pas pendant la campagne je
rappelle des études d'opinion mesuraient
la popularité des différentes réformes
que nous portions pendant les élections
législatives notamment parce que nous
avons fait campagne de façon
transparente ça n'était pas la réforme
des retraites qui venait tout en haut du
classement et bien nous le faisons quand
même parce que nous avons cette esprit
de responsabilité et parce que je veux
souligner ici grâce aux efforts
collectifs on va pouvoir corriger des
injustices on va pouvoir améliorer les
pensions de retraite notamment des plus
faibles pensions du pays de ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et qui ont
aujourd'hui en vue le bénéfice de 100
euros par mois de pouvoir passer de 1100
à 1200 euros de pension de retraite je
pense que ça c'est tout à fait important
alors parmi les choses qui peuvent être
abordées ou améliorées dans le dans le
projet vous évoquez un travail sur les
inégalités les carrières hachées le
travail des employabilité des seniors
peut-être qu'on peut revenir sur ces sur
ces différents points par exemple vous
venez d'évoquer les les la pension
minimale est-ce qu'elle sera bien de
1200 euros brut pour toutes les
personnes qui ont une carrière complète
Olivier du socle vous entendre que il
pourrait y avoir quelques difficultés
techniques par rapport à ça non pas des
difficultés techniques il y a eu
quelques confusions sur le brut ou le
net je veux être possible ce matin pour
pour
soulever oulever ce point de friction ce
serait possible de passer à 1200 € net
pour minimum et je vais essayer de
m'expliquer d'abord c'est 85 euros du
SMIC
ça commence bien si je vais expliquer en
disant euro à la place de pour cent 85%
du SMIC net voilà parce qu'il y a eu
d'abord une première confusion et
ensuite sont effectivement 1200 euros
brut mais quand on dit ça on laisse
parfois à penser qu'il y a les mêmes
charges que vous avez quand vous avez
votre salaire brut ce n'est pas le cas
une pension de retraite il y a
simplement la CSG dessus la CSG elle
peut être variable en fonction de la
composition du foyer c'est pour ça que
m'ont pas donné un montant de CSG pour
les personnes concernées sont souvent
les plus faibles rémunérations sont la
majorité du temps dans une CSG à taux
très réduit donc ce seront quelques
dizaines d'euros qui seront retranchés
de ces 1200 euros voilà pour être
parfaitement clair donc il y a pas
d'ambiguïté sur cette question là il y a
simplement la CSG qui continuera de
s'appliquer comme pour toutes les
pensions de retraite sur la pension
minimum mais il y aura pas de
l'augmentation de 100 euros par rapport
à ce qui était la pension minimum
auparavant elle sera intacte d'une
certaine façon puisque ce qu'il faut
presser c'est que la CSG elle
s'appliquait aussi sur la pension
minimum avant la réforme des retraites
donc je pense qu'il faut de la clarté
tout simplement sont des sujets qui sont
très rapidement techniques parce qu'il
faut regarder toutes les lignes d'une
certaine façon mais en l'expliquant bien
je pense qu'on montre autre point il y a
une vraie mesure de justice qui est
d'augmenter de façon significative les
plus faibles pensions dans notre pays
autre point de friction est-ce que vous
reviendrez sur les 44 annuités
nécessaires pour les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler plus tôt mais on
demande à tous un effort voilà là encore
je pense qu'il dire les choses très
clairement pour certaines personnes deux
ans de plus c'est la majorité si
personne sur dix et puis pour d'autres
un an de plus c'est le cas des personnes
que vous mentionnez donc cet effort il
est moins moindre pour ces personnes là
mais ça reste un effort quand même
toutes les parlementaires on écoute les
modifications il y a des parlementaires
et notamment LR qui sont plutôt en
classe soutenir c'est intéressant qui
disent sur les 44 annuités ça c'est pas
possible ça veut dire que là-dessus vous
me laissez pas c'est que tel quel est le
texte que nous présentons au Parlement
il a été travaillé en conscience en
lucidité sur l'ensemble de ces points là
si les parlementaires souhaitent revenir
précisément sur cet aspect et l'envisage
comme un enrichissement prioritaire du
texte il y a ils seront libres de
pouvoir voter le texte de cette façon là
mais dans un cadre je veux rappeler
devant vous
d'équilibre glosses économies si
beaucoup sur ces 44 ans est-ce que vous
accepterez que
une personne ne travaille plus de 40 ans
retravailler l'équilibre d'ensemble pour
que la copie de sortie puisse rester
équilibrée nous vous avez compris que le
projet que nous pouvons revenir oui pour
revenir sur ces 44 ans de trouver
d'autres sources d'économie de façon
générale je pense pouvoir dire et je
sors de ma condition en le disant je le
travaille évidemment avec Olivier du
soft avec la première ministre et
Olivier du socle et le ministre en
charge des grands équilibres de cette
réforme et donc il y aura un dialogue
avec le gouvernement mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que le gouvernement n'est pas
insensible ou sourd à toutes les
revendications mais est très claire sur
un équilibre global et donc ces
modifications ces enrichissements il
faudra les porter dans le cadre d'un
système qui reste équilibré c'est-à-dire
responsable vis-à-vis de générations
futures vous défendez beaucoup une
réforme juste c'est un mot qu'on entend
dans la bouche de l'exécutif pourtant
hier sur notre antenne Franck Riesser le
ministère j'ai des relations avec le
Parlement a reconnu que les femmes
seraient un pénalisé par cette réforme
on est quand même loin d'une réforme
juste du coup ça dépend ce qu'on veut
dire par pénaliser
vous faites mention de ce qui ressort de
l'étude d'impact de cette réforme là
aussi il faut dire les choses de façon
transparente et complète la durée de
cotisation des femmes va augmenter un
peu légèrement à celle des hommes en
moyenne mais il faut apporter plusieurs
précisions d'abord les femmes
continueront de partir à un âge de
départ effectif à la retraite similaire
à celui des hommes après la réforme par
rapport à avant la réforme puis la
deuxième précision qu'il faut apporter
c'est que la pension de retraite des
femmes va en revanche augmenter
significativement plus fortement que
celle des hommes et donc c'est ça dire
les choses de façon complète avant la
réforme vous allez 30% d'écart de
pension entre les femmes et les hommes
après la réforme à terme on va réduire
d'un tiers cet écart et donc c'est ça
aussi la justice qui a porté par cette
réforme là elle réclame des efforts
collectifs mais va permettre d'améliorer
les pensions de retraite et
significativement dans les trimestres
sont 30% des femmes qui vont bénéficier
de l'augmentation de la pension minimale
qu'on mentionnait à l'instant sont 15%
des hommes simplement donc dans son
ensemble oui je dis que cette réforme
est une réforme juste une réforme
nécessaire c'est-à-dire qu'elle réclame
un effort collectif un allongement de la
durée du travail mais cette allongement
la durée de travail il va permettre de
financer des améliorations du système il
va permettre de diminuer des injustices
concernant la rémunération entre les
femmes et les hommes le travail va pas
s'arrêter là et on voit bien que ces
inégalités à la retraite elles sont
générées par des inégalités dans la
carrière et donc c'est ça aussi qu'il
faut continuer à travailler
à essayer de faire en sorte ou de
dissimuler des choses issues de l'étude
d'impact c'est pour ça pardon j'ai
j'essaie de vous répondre de façon un
tout petit peu complète il faut dire des
choses à la fois sur l'augmentation de
la durée de cotisation mais aussi sur
l'augmentation significative des
pensions de retraite et ça compte vous
avez évoqué la question d'employabilité
des seniors tout à l'heure est-ce que ça
c'est pas un gros point ou un gros
problème qui leur a fallu résoudre avant
de proposer cette réforme et de reporter
l'âge de départ et là je crois qu'on est
le pays d'Europe qui a le plus faible
taux d'employabilité c'est oui vous avez
raison mais il faut travailler sur ces
questions en même temps on peut faire
une réforme des retraites ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire un
index senior et obliger les entreprises
à le publier c'est du pipeau c'est pas
ça qui mécaniquement va améliorer
l'employeurs il faut dire une chose vous
mentionnez à la comparaison avec les
autres pays européens après la réforme
des retraites après cette réforme des
retraites en France nous continuerons
d'être le pays où l'on part le plus tôt
en Europe avec le système de retraite le
plus généreux d'Europe et donc ça aussi
je crois que c'est un fait incontestable
et donc il faut dire cela quand on
compare avec les autres pays européens
et c'est à dire qu'on va baisser les
bras cette question absolument cruciale
de l'emploi des seniors cruciales pour
notre économie cruciale pour les
parcours de carrière crucial pour les
gens qui sont concernés évidemment qu'on
va pas continuer et qu'on va pas baisser
les bras donc on va agir on va agir en
travaillant avec des entreprises elles
ont une large part de responsabiliser
sur l'employabilité des seniors on va
agir dans l'emploi public aussi je me
permets de le dire en tant que ministre
de la Fonction publique parce que nous
allons introduire comment vous allez des
mesures justement pour pouvoir mieux
aménager les carrières moi c'est le cœur
de mes chantiers c'est que j'ai lancé
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
avec les organisations syndicales de
pouvoir proposer des améliorations de
carrière vous voyez ça n'était pas
explicable qu'au fond à la fin d'une
carrière professionnelle on puisse dans
la fonction publique aussi difficilement
changer de métier là on va faire en
sorte justement ce qui n'était pas
possible avant de pouvoir par exemple
changer de métier entre des métiers
pénibles ben ça soit rendu possible je
vais être très concret avant que nous
passion cette réforme des retraites
parce que je suis convaincu que il faut
aller au bout mais vous aviez un système
ou si vous abandonnez votre métier
pénible pour passer derrière un bureau à
la fin de ce cas un professionnel dans
l'administration vous perdez tout le
bénéfice du temps passé sur le terrain
bah nous allons mettre fin justement à
ce qui est une injustice je vais
travailler ce qu'on appelle la demande
oui bien entendu avant
une carrière oui aussi quand on était
policier je termine juste là dessus et
que on devenait douanier mais on perdait
tout le bénéfice de ces années passées
et bien ça c'est fini oui on va aussi
aménager les carrières pour vous
répondre très directement nous allons
introduire ce qui n'était pas existant
dans la fonction publique c'est à dire
un dispositif de retraite progressive ça
va permettre pour un professeur par
exemple d'avoir la possibilité de se
mettre à temps partiel à la fin de sa
carrière professionnelle dans
l'administration et de conserver sa
rémunération parce que on va pouvoir
bénéficier de sa pension de retraite ce
sont des grands inventions des
évolutions dans le mode de calcul de la
retraite pour les partenaires est-ce que
il y aura une intégration des primes par
exemple je vais être très clair là aussi
on bouge de façon symétrique l'effort
qui est demandé à tous les actifs du
pays privés et public donc les deux
années de recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite elle s'appliqueront aussi au
fonctionnaires du pays c'est l'équité
que de faire comme cela ce que nous
allons conserver c'est les modes de
calcul donc cette réforme c'est pas une
convergence systémique des deux systèmes
qui je le dis n'étaient pas prêt à
pouvoir converger donc on va conserver
les caractéristiques fondamentales le
calcul de pension de retraite des
fonctionnaires à la fois la question des
six derniers mois ça continuera de
s'appliquer comme tel mais aussi de
l'assiette de cotisations qui continuera
d'être l'assiette indiciaire c'est à
dire qui ne compte pas les primes des
fonctionnalités
sur deux systèmes qui ne sont pas prêts
à la convergence aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup d'hétérogénéité entre les
différentes catégories de fonctionnaires
en 2019 c'était l'ambition on voyait
bien que elle était extrêmement complexe
elle avait d'ailleurs généré beaucoup de
crainte chez les fonctionnaires parce
que la bascule d'un système à l'autre et
extrêmement complexe mais ce qu'il faut
dire très simplement parce que j'entends
parfois que le système de retraite des
fonctionnaires ça a privilégierait les
fonctionnaires par rapport au salaire du
privé moi je veux tordre le coup à cette
idée là ce qu'il faut regarder au fond
c'est le taux de remplacement c'est ça
le juge de paix c'est qu'est-ce que vous
avez votre retraite par rapport à ce que
vous avez pour votre carrière et on
constate que le taux de remplacement des
fonctionnaires il est strictement
identique à 74% au taux de remplacement
les salariés du privé je pense que c'est
bon d'avoir ce paramètre en tête quand
on aborde
sur la question des contrats actuels
comment là vous faites pour intégrer
notamment la question de la pénibilité
notamment peut-être chez dans la
fonction publique hospitalière à
l'hôpital évidemment c'est plus
compliqué vous avez un peu plus de
100000 aide-soignants dans la fonction
publique hospitalière qui sont
contractuelles c'est-à-dire qu'ils font
le même amitié que des titulaires que
des fonctionnaires qui sont eux
catégories actives qui n'ont aucun
bénéfice de leur année passée et donc ce
que nous allons faire parce que nous
allons pouvoir financer ces
améliorations et on va proposer à ces
contractuels là quand ils seront
titularisés dans la fonction publique
que leurs années passées en tant que
actuelle elle compte pas pour du beurre
mais elle soit intégrée dans leur calcul
et dans leur durée de service pour
calculer leur métier pénible ça c'est
une vraie amélioration elle était
demandée par les organisations
syndicales à juste titre et bien grâce à
la réforme on va pouvoir donner suite à
cette demande là
sur la procédure oui le gouvernement a
choisi de passer par le 47.1 article 47
ans de la Constitution qui limite le
temps des débats au Parlement ça ça n'a
jamais été utilisé pour une pour une
réforme des des retraites est-ce que
c'est ce que vous redoutez un enlisement
une obstruction est-ce que d'abord le
gouvernement a pas fait le choix de 47
ans le gouvernement a fait le choix
d'avoir un texte qui est un pfss un
projet un projet de loi de de la
sécurité sociale ce qui est pas
illégitime quand il s'agit de prendre
des mesures sur les retraites qui sont
justement adossés à la sécurité sociale
suite il y a le choix d'examen parce que
vous saviez qu'il y avait une
obstruction
je vais venir il y a un temps d'examen
qui est pas je le dis très sincèrement
indigne pour examiner un projet de loi
de retraite 50 jours de débats doit
permettre d'avoir un débat de qualité
entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale
puis je trouve parfois contradictoire
des attaques ou des critiques qui
viennent de l'opposition et ils ont pas
avoir assez de temps pour débattre mais
par contre on va déposer des centaines
de milliers d'amendements pour justement
rendre impossible
finalement on déposera pas des
puissent revenir à la raison sur cette
question là parce que c'est absolument
incompréhensible qu'à la fois de
critiquer le manque de débat et de
l'enliser totalement et de le rendre
impossible donc moi ce que je souhaite
je crois avec la première ministre
l'ensemble du gouvernement c'est que
nous puissions avoir un débat de qualité
on peut ne pas être d'accord c'est la
démocratie mais il faut qu'on puisse
débattre argument contre argument et
permettre à la démocratie justement de
vivre pleinement merci Stan merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité on se
via évidemment ce débat qui commence au
Parlement dès la semaine prochaine en
commission merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité on accueille notre
prochaine invité politique c'est Olivier